[Applause]
at the angel in burford it's too late to
offer salvation to the christmas trade
concern about omicron as slash custom
and takings in this corner of the
cotswolds as it has across the country
leaving pubs half empty and the brewery
with more beer than they can sell in
what should be the busiest time of year
it's been pretty grim really you know we
were looking forward to a good december
because december's very much the time
that hospitality hopefully gets someone
in the bank to see them through the
darker days of january and february but
the last two three weeks have been
really really tough bookings cancelled
across the across the whole landscape a
fortnight after omicron began to hit
trade the under pressure chancellor
announced one billion pounds worth of
support including grants and sick pay
for hospitality businesses and the
promise of more if lockdowns return
now of course
i will always respond proportionately
and appropriately to the situation that
we face people can have confidence in
that but where we are now we've
responded i think generously today the
grants that we've outlined up to 6 000
pounds are comparable to the grants that
we provided for hospitality businesses
when they were completely closed earlier
this year
the angels licensee gemma it's welcome
but what she really wants to know is if
restrictions around the corner well i
mean it's better than nothing for sure
um but to be honest it just doesn't
touch the sides for our business
businesses like us and for us i think
with a 40 reduction in revenue which i
don't think makes this unique i think
that's quite typical across the board
we're losing a huge amount more than 6
000 pounds
the measures set a precedent by offering
financial support to businesses hit not
by forced closures but the collapse in
consumer confidence this one billion
pound package is a fraction of that
which was offered earlier in the
pandemic but it's justified by the fact
it's these hospitality businesses that
are paying the price for the public
following government health advice what
happens next though remains deeply
uncertain
businesses across the economy still
can't be certain what restrictions might
apply next week let alone next year
businesses are just asking for clarity
of message from government any forward
guidance they can
give to businesses businesses want to do
their part but they need time to prepare
to be ready
for any change in the way in which they
need to operate to protect health
30 million pounds has been made
available to cultural institutions like
the natural history museum hit by staff
absences
sickness and self-isolation has brought
curtains down across the west end too a
scary and costly finale for the festive
season
paul kelso sky news in barford